Eddie Redmayne and wife Hannah welcome  baby number two et can confirm the 36  year old actors wife gave birth to their  second child a baby boy on Saturday  March 10 Eddie and Hannah named their  new bundle of joy Luke  Richard Bagshaw the two have been  married for three years and are already  parents two daughter iris Mary born in  June 2016 what's your favorite part  about it is waking up every morning  probably if she slept through the night  when you go into and she's so excited to  see another day and there's nothing  untainted et spoke with the fantastic  beasts star in June 2017 where he opened  up about what it was like to become a  father for the first time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]